esta madrugada estuvo marcada por
ataques múltiples de las fuerzas rusas
que lanzaron misiles no solamente desde
el mar negro sino también desde la rusa
estos misiles habrían atacado
principalmente a la región de cherne bit
en el norte este del país pero también
alcanzaron a la ciudad de kiev y
mykolaiv donde nos encontramos una de
las ciudades que son constantemente
atacadas por las fuerzas rusas aquí se
conoce que uno de los misiles cayó en un
colegio otro en una universidad donde
enseñan navegación marítima y un tercero
habría alcanzado las proximidades de una
iglesia hoy es un día especial para
ucrania celebra por primera vez en una
fiesta conmemora desde el año pasado que
es como el carácter de la nación esta es
la primera vez que lo celebraban y se
cree que esto ha sido aprovechado por
rusia para lanzar este múltiple ataque
en un momento donde continúa esta
contraofensiva para retomar la región de
gerson muy próximo al lugar donde nos
encontramos en esta provincia de mikko
life